typiquement les objets qu'on peut
déposer qu'on peut trouver
du petit mobilier de l'électroménager
des livres de la déco le principe est
simple vous déposez vos objets usagés et
leur offrez une nouvelle vie à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux dans l'une des 7
déchetteries de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines un caisson de
réemploi peut être utilisé par les
habitants le but de l'initiative ne pas
créer de déchets dans la lignée de ce
qu'on essaye de mettre en place depuis
2016 que la compétence a été transférée
des communes vers l'agglomération
l'objectif est toujours d'aller vers
moins de déchets donc ça se traduit par
différentes actions et notamment la
dernière en date c'est la création de ce
caisson après quelques difficultés au
démarrage le dispositif s'inscrit
aujourd'hui dans le quotidien des cinq
continents la déchetterie a récolté 200
kg d'objets au mois d'août contre 50 ans
d'avril jouait DVD meubles et même vélo
les habitants jouent le jeu sa première
fois effectivement que je dépose mes
objets ici habituellement je vais chez
Emmaüs qui est pas très loin de la
maison ça puisse être recyclé et
que ça puisse servir à d'autres
personnes gérée par trois associations
ressourcez-vous la bicyclette et Emmaüs
trap la restauration est assurée dans
leurs ateliers si l'objet n'est pas
réutilisable il bascule dans les
filières de traitement traditionnel
c'est vraiment bénéfique et c'est
vraiment vertueux l'idée étant qu'il
regarde ce qui est fonctionnel si s'il y
a besoin d'une petite réparation et il
le remettent ensuite dans le circuit via
leur filière et ça pourra servir comme
ça à tout un tas d'autres personnes
exclusivement réservé aux cinq
continents le caisson est pour le moment
situé sur un site pilote mais si
l'expérience est positive
l'agglomération prévoit de le déployer
sur d'autres déchetteries dès 2024 en
fonction de la place disponible